♪
>> WE’RE HERE TO SHOW OUR
RESPECT FOR ALL WOMEN WHO HAVE A
CASE, HAVE IT RESPECTED, DUE
PROCESS, TO INVESTIGATE.
>> THERE’S A LOT OF EXCITEMENT
AROUND THE IDEA THAT WOMEN WILL
BE HEARD AND BE LISTENED TO.
>> IT TOOK GREAT COURAGE FOR HER
TO COME FORWARD.
>> THERE WAS NEVER ANY RECORD.
AND THAT NOBODY EVER CAME
FORWARD.
>> INSTEAD OF ASKING QUESTIONS,
THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP HEARS
THE TRUTH.
>> THERE IS ALSO DUE PROCESS.
AND THE FACT THAT JOE BIDEN IS
JOE BIDEN.
PETE: NANCY THEN AND NANCY NOW.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
DEFENDING JOE BIDEN HE’S DENIES
HIS SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATION
BUT IT WAS A DIFFERENT TUNE FOR
JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH.
JASON: AND IN A NEW FOX NEWS
OP-ED SENATOR MARSHA BLACKBURN
CALLS OUT THE MEDIA FOR THE SAME
DOUBLE STANDARD.
SENATOR BLACKBURN JOINS US NOW.
I HAD THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING WITH HER.
>> YES, INDO.
JASON: IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTING.
NOW SHE IS SITTING ON THE VERY
POWERFUL SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND YOU SAW UP CLOSE
AND PERSONAL WHAT HAPPENED TO
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
>> YES, INDEED I DID.
AND WHAT WE ARE JUST FASCINATED
WITH RIGHT NOW IS THE DOUBLE
STANDARD.
AND, JASON, I WILL TELL YOU SO
MANY WAYMAN THAT HAVE REACHED
OUT TO ME THIS WEEK ARE TALKING
ABOUT FAIRNESS.
AND THEY SEE A LACK OF FAIRNESS
IN THIS ISSUE AROUND TARA READE.
AND THEY FEEL AS IF THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT HAS ACTUALLY SERVED A
PURPOSE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THEIR DAUGHTERS AND
GRANDDAUGHTER TO SAY SOMETHING
WRONG WAS DONE TO ME BUT THEN
THEY SEE THE DEMOCRAT USING ME
TOO WHEN IT’S CONVENIENT AND
DISMISSING IT WHEN IT IS NOT
CONVENIENT.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, LISTENING
TO JOE BIDEN’S INTERVIEW
YESTERDAY, I SAID WE SHOULD CALL
THIS THE PREPFUL DEFENSE.
HE WAS ON EVERY SIDE AND
CONTRADICTING HIMSELF AND
TWISTING HIMSELF IN KNOTS AS HE
GAVE THAT INTERVIEW YESTERDAY.
PETE: CAN’T SAY IT ENOUGH
WITHOUT DOUBLE STANDARDS THE
LEFT PROBABLY WOULDN’T HAVE ANY
STANDARDS.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
PETE: NOT JUST THE POLITICAL
LEFT.
BUDDIES IN THE MEDIA TAKING A
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH AT THIS
MOMENT.
TAKE A WATCH HE WAS INCREDIBLY
DEFIANT NO.
GRAY AREA.
THIS IS BLACK AND WHITE.
THIS SIMPLY DID NOT HAPPEN.
>> CALLED FOR FULL TRANSPARENCY
ON THE RECORD.
THAT’S WHAT NEEDED TO HAPPEN.
THAT’S WHAT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
LET’S BE CLEAR, IN THE KAVANAUGH
HEARING.
>> THE RIGHT IS RUNNING A SMEAR
CAMPAIGN AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
>> SO, IT’S JUST A SMEAR
SENATOR.
>> MARCIA, THIS IS A VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE.
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SHOWER.
IS A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND SHOULD BE TREATED AS SUCH.
IT SHOULD NOT BE SOMETHING THAT
IS USED AS A POLITICAL FOOTBALL
OR AS A TERM OF CONVENIENCE TO
SUIT THE PURPOSES OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE DETERMINED TO TAKE DOWN
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY DO NOT WANT ANYTHING TO
HAPPEN TO JOE BIDEN.
THEY ARE SO DETERMINED TO TAKE
DOWN PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT THEY
ARE ACTUALLY GOING DISMISS
SOMEONE WHO HAS CORROBORATING
EVIDENCE.
SHE TALKED TO PEOPLE.
HER MOTHER CALLED LARRY KING.
AND WE WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
I THINK THAT TRUTH WILL COME
OUT.
WE KNOW THAT VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS HAD A HISTORY OF
TOUCHING PEOPLE AND KISSING AND
MAKING THEM UNCOMFORTABLE.
AND EVEN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
HAD TO GO BACK IN AND ALTER AN
ARTICLE THAT THEY HAD PUT UP
ONLINE DEALING WITH SOME OF HIS
KNOWN BEHAVIORS.
THIS IS SERIOUS.
TARA READE DESERVES TO BE HEARD
JUST LIKE OTHER WOMEN DESERVE TO
BE HEARD.
THIS NEEDS TO BE REVIEWED AND
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO COME FORWARD
AND JUST TELL THE TRUTH.
JILLIAN: SENATOR.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THIS FOR A
SECOND HERE BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
DEALING WITH THE CORONAVIRUS HAS
BECOME A BIT PARTISAN.
YOU COULD SAY THAT THE SENATE IS
RETURNING TO WORK ON MONDAY.
WHAT DO YOU SEE HAPPENING THIS
WEEK?
>> WELL, WE’RE WHAT WE’RE GOING
IS MOVE FORWARD ON SOME OF THE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
WE CAN WALK AND CHEW GUM AT THE
SAME TIME YOU IF YOU WILL.
THERE ARE JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS.
THERE ARE NOMINATIONS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT NEED TO BE
LOOKED AT.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE AN ARMED
SERVICES HEARING.
AND WE’RE GOING TO BE WORK
ONLINE PRIVACY.
AND JILLIAN, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS COME FORWARD THROUGH
COVID-19 IS THE LACK OF ONLINE
PRIVACY AND THE LACK OF
INDIVIDUALS.
YOU AND I INDIVIDUALLY BEING
ABLE TO CONTROL WHAT I CALL OUR
VIRTUAL YOU.
DECIDING IF WE WANT TO OPT IN TO
SHARE INFORMATION OR NOT.
REQUIRING COMPANIES TO INFORM US
WHEN THEY ARE DATA MINING.
AND REVIEWING INFORMATION FROM
US.
AND THIS HEALTH PRIVACY, WHICH
IN THE PHYSICAL SPACE IS
CONTROLLED BY HIP PARKS WE ARE
GOING TO CHAIRMAN WICKER AT
COMMERCE COMMITTEE AND A COUPLE
OF OTHERS OF US HAVE LEGISLATION
THAT IS BEING INTRODUCED NEXT
WEEK TO DEAL WITH THAT WE ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE TURNING OUR
ATTENTION TO HOLDING CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
WHETHER IT IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH HAVING CHINA WAIVE THE
INTEREST PAYMENTS ON THEIR DEBT,
SOMETHING I HAVE SUPPORTED.
MOVING MANUFACTURING BACK TO
U.S. SOIL.
AND SENATOR MENDEZ AND I HAVE
THE SAM C BILL MOVES
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURING
BACK TO THE U.S.
SENATOR SULLIVAN AND OTHERS HAVE
OTHER PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
WILL MOVE MANUFACTURING BACK.
SENATOR McSALLY AND REP GOODEN
AND I HAVE THE STOP COVID ACT
THAT WILL PUT INTO THE HANDS OF
U.S. CITIZENS THE ABILITY TO SUE
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY FOR
THEIR ROLE IN THIS PANDEMIC.
AND WE’LL GIVE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE LOST LIVES AND LIVELY
HOODS THE ABILITY TO GO INTO
U.S. COURTS.
SO, ALL OF THAT IS ON THE AGENDA
FOR THIS WEEK.
JASON: SENATOR, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
IT’S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> SURE.
JASON: I APPLAUD THE SENATE FOR
BEING IN SESSION.
THE HOUSE IS NOT GOING TO BE IN
SESSION.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.